did you hear about keanu reeves what the
keanu reeves talked about yeah so
interesting uh take on kiana reeves uh
did you see that one girl whose story
went viral yeah with the mother how
awesome is her mom's like i'm about to
take a picture with keanu reeves just
like i have no idea what this guy is but
i'll take a picture with camera whatever
it goes viral here's kendall reeves okay
matrix star keanu reeves owns crypto
skeptical of nfds says we cannot have
metaverse be invented by facebook famous
hollywood actor cryptocurrencies
tokens during the interview reeves
commented on the metaverse on facebook
the social media giant that recently
changed his name to meta can we just not
have metaverse be invented by facebook
he said on the subject of non-fungible
tokens reefs was asked whether he has
seen matrix nfts for the upcoming matrix
resurrection movie he admitted that he
has not seen them and wondered if he and
moss are getting paid at all for them
when asked what he thought about the
concept of digital scarcity reeves
laughed and added that they are still
easily reproduced what are your thoughts
on nfts well i
i think the whole metaverse is is i'm
trying to get my
head around
but like for example nike you're gonna
be able to go in the metaverse and go
into a nike store in the metaverse and
buy a non-fungible token and then come
out to the real world and then buy that
real world shoe
yeah like it's it's
an interplay but i mean do i have some
mana some sand i have some of those
tokens but
uh i'm still trying to get my head
around it you know the
buying land in the metaverse patches
told you man if you're on your phone
2500 3500 times a day the next
the next uh
the next progression is in the phone man
and um again
the dopamine is going to be something
that our brains are not going to be able
to get off of you're going to be able to
live your life as your idealized self in
the in the metaverse you want to be six
foot five you want to have abs you want
to dunk you want you you want your
girlfriend to look like barbie all of
that's possible in the metaverse it's
not possible in the real world so what
do you two think in fts
i think it's a beautiful way to launder
money
yeah i don't think it's going away i
think it's been around for a while now
if you played any video games and you
would buy the additional stuff that
would come with it buy a weapon for five
bucks buy this for 10 bucks buy this for
20 bucks
i remember one time me and my friends
okay stephen awful were in where were we
we're in panama okay
and we're at the uh panama canal and my
friend is sitting down his phone's
playing this game i don't know what you
clash of something so he's playing this
game
clash of titans clash of types yeah and
and i said so what's going on here and
one the guy says you know he spent
already five thousand dollars on that
game i said how much he said five
thousand i said what do you do with five
thousand dollars on this game
i said get video games like i remember
street fighter was 74.95 i remember when
he came out as fast
he says oh no this is different let me
tell you what i'm buying look at the
weapon look at this look at that look at
this
what are you talking about so if a 40
year old deca millionaire which is that
friend of mine is that's exactly the
situation he's in
if he's spending five thousand dollars
on a game he's essentially buying
non-fungible tokens so it's been around
for a long long time
it's officially now at a point where
they're trying to get the rest of the
world to know that this is the direction
we're going well here's nothing you can
do about here's what's screwy about what
you just said
so what you do in those games is you buy
time
because as you as you increase your your
castle as you increase your land it
takes longer to farm it takes longer to
build up clowns
yeah clash of titans is better but clash
of clans is good too the uh anyway so
the the uh the point i'm trying to make
is that in the metaverse one of the
things that that if you want to get real
trippy twilight zoney
the logical conclusion of this is
downloading your
consciousness
into the metaverse
living forever as your idealized self
as long as you can afford to buy more
time right
so as long as you can afford and that's
a movie five more times what was the
movie time i don't know what yeah it was
called yeah so i mean but that's
that's uh i don't think it's going away
look there's two things that's going to
drive nfts and the meta here's what it
is number one
what is your system
when you lay in bed and you close your
eyes where do you go to
so so you're either thinking about
issues you're dealing with
you're thinking about your kids your
husband your wife your girlfriend your
boyfriend your mom's health your dad's
health your business a job interview a
project
something
or you're fantasizing about something
yeah like oh my gosh how's it going to
be when i go to europe and my your brain
just goes right okay that's a meta
essentially you're living in la la land
and we've been doing this for a while
except it's your own meta that i cannot
be a part of sure it's only one person's
matter that's your matter and i'm
concerned about the medal your wife
i don't i don't know if i want to go to
[Music]
history in my metabolism
some people's meta they ain't know what
it's it's a whole different you don't
want you don't even want to smell my
matter
okay but but that is a form of meta
right and here's the other part why i
don't think this is going away
i think you know somebody said what an
idiot who the hell would spend five
thousand dollars it's called competition
man capitalism is based on competition
we like to compete we want to do better
we want to be on our leaders bulletin we
want to be ranked we want to have
something to say here's what i am
as long as your imagination doesn't go
away and as long as competition is going
to be the main currency
nftn meadow's not going to go away dude
it's immortality it's so much bigger
than that yeah it's immortality if you
had the option and if you had the
resources to live forever your family
live forever
would you do it
i mean it's not even a hypothetical
question it's maybe a matter of
technological advancement you know you
talk about it i wrote a book about it
the fiction book you've read the book
the book is about that that's partly a
meta and took me ten years to finish
this book and we're right now we just
finished it right now we're pitching it
to uh publishers we just
finished the what do you call it the
marketing uh for the book and we'll be
going to different publishers to see uh
what direction we're gonna go with this
but that is essentially what you're
talking about what happens when your
meta life is so much better than your
real life that's the that's the problem
everybody's going to be
the john you may want to put down my
clothes it's not a problem of the
of the
system it's
the backbone of the system your
idealized self your dream world is going
to be so much better than the real world
you're never coming out with what
there's going to be people who
become
david thoreau go to the woods live
deliberately i want to feel
i want i want to look at the real sky i
want to breathe the real air and they're
going to there's going to be those half
of society that they're going to be real
they're going to want to go skydiving
they want real danger they want to feel
real things they want to have
unprotected sex they want to feel life
and then there's going to be people that
are in the metaverse that are safe
they're totally controlled they can't
say anything bad they have to acquiesce
all their freedom to whatever you know
controlling organism but they get the
trade-off as they get to be their
idealized self right they get to do
whatever they've ever dreamed of doing
that they can't do in the real world
they can do it here and that's it that
the serotonin and the dopamine that
that's going to cause i mean right now
you've got guys that you know there's uh
there's a great comedian that i know
mike sicoley unbelievable guy he goes uh
my life is so much better in grand theft
auto than my regular life yeah and i die
a hundred times an hour
like he's like he's like i die a hundred
times an hour gta my life is so much
better in the game what percentage of
people do you think
uh prefer their imaginary life over
their real life what do you think that
is
i mean it's high of course so why do
people do drugs why do people do alcohol
to escape reality i mean we've been
wanting to escape reality for
a long time most people's escaping of
reality is video games or you know
smoking weed or doing ecstasy and doing
whatever they do that is their form i
just don't want to deal with the life i
currently have and there's nothing i can
do about it
so you're you're bitter about it you
have a way to escape it so
that is part of the motive and the
attraction i can escape it and it's a
different form of a drug and i'm going
to be addicted to it that's just kind of
how this thing's going to be
i think the drug analogy is the perfect
dentist are you are your parents still
alive if you don't mind no okay
imagine if their consciousness were
uploaded to the metaverse and you can go
to the metaverse and have dinner with
your mother whenever you wanted to
what would that be worth to you a lot
especially if she was cooking
would would it
would it would it matter would it matter
to you that the food you were eating
wasn't real
no probably not right not if it was her
chicken and dumplings and cornbread
making me hungry
i mean that that's
you know look we think about the crazy
things and we think about like you know
the ability to fly and all this like
fantasy stuff and that's definitely part
of it but then there's that actual that
realization of like you know what man
like if my parents yeah
if
you know if my parents consciousness
gets uploaded i mean look my parents are
a little bit older i go home twice a
year if my parents live another 10 years
i've got 20 times to see my mother 20
2-0 and that's the whole reason to work
people the whole reason to work the
whole reason to put up with the
and make money is because money's worth
time right and if you can double that
and see your parents four times a year
you double the amount of time you have
with them the metaverse you can see them
forever right forever
yeah how many people want to have a
conversation with their deceased parents
that's that's the price point i mean
listen the whole part about being a born
again what is the idea that you're
eventually going to see the people you
love that are no longer here with you
in heaven yeah meta is a form of a
secular heaven is how it's being sold so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]